thank you yes message yeah okay all
right
um thanks um very much to the organizers
for holding us fantastic workshop and um
um
uh so and I don't need an introduction
because Kevin David
um so my paper is also concerned with
this uh you know what this consumer
behavior and this very socially
connected news Market in which we now
live
um but my focus is different the focus
is going to be on how all of this
consumer Behavior affects the producers
of the news
so we're going to be trying to
understand how when consumers do all of
the sharing of the news and they're
giving putting stuff on everybody's feed
how does that feedback to producers and
then how does that producers and
feedback to Consumers and so on so this
is Joint work with David McAdams it's
some paper that we've been working on
for quite some time we're revising it
now in the midst of a revision so of
course this is a fantastic time for um
so um you know in this world out there
where people are worried about how news
travels so quickly and you know and
supplement shows up on everybody's
speeds there are some policies uh that
have been suggested to actually slow
that down and so one of them was a
policy by Facebook to limit forwarding
on messenger to only a few some limit of
groups or other people so our objective
is to get a sense of what might a policy
like that look like in a news market so
again I'm in this world and I'll I'll
show you my my model of the world where
consumers are sharing stories
um in this where everyone sort of thinks
this is possibly bad because fake news
travels widely and so on and so forth
what might the limits on sharing news
um due to the news market and
particularly we're concerned about the
people which are out there producing the
news the people who are going out
um you know investigating um publishing
on news stories all the media
influencers who are presumably testing
out products for us and so on so what we
do in this paper is we build a model of
a contemporary connected information
um
and I want you to think of information
Market really broadly they'll all be
talking mostly about media so news
stories
I'll be talking about the news media we
can also think about social influencers
we can also think about us we're out
here producing stuff we want people to
see it we get benefits from when a lot
of people see what our production is
okay so um
let's see so what are the features of
the model
um the featured model that we have many
providers of information and relative to
some earlier world where uh we didn't
have all of this um technology they
perhaps can Broadcast News
um
uh you know they can produce news more
cheaply than we could have before in the
old world or where we only have brick
and mortar producers
um but in this world we do still have
the brick and mortar media who's moved
online we also bloggers influencers and
we have our Infamous basement dwellers
who may be off just you know spouting
stuff
um the consumers uh are connected on
social media which means that news has a
very very large potential reach
um our consumers are possibly
sophisticated so again thanks Kevin you
know they're they're doing something
they look at the news stories they
decide to share with their neighbors of
course this goes back to some of the
early work I've done about sort of when
consumers want to spread things to their
neighbors in a network so consumers are
also doing that
another book I guess
okay so let me give you a sense of the
of these different pieces so I have a
simple model of consumer um of demand
consumer demand for information so
consumers are going to Value high
quality information so we're going to
have high quality news and low quality
news they low on high quality news
because it helps them guide future
actions like voting consumers are going
to tune in to information broadcasts
and possibly share stories after
checking their own private signals as to
whether or not this particular news
story is going to be helpful for
somebody else
um consumers then follow other consumers
so they see the stories that another
consumer has shared with that
so we're going to obviously have Network
effects actually we have a very very
simple thing which actually activity
call it a network because we cut it off
you'll see very very simple Network
um we do have these effects of sharing
so the consumers are
doing a quality filter for their friends
and neighbors so I read a story in the
New York Times about vaccines I decide
whether or not to share it with my
mother and then my mother then says oh
well you know Rachel share this with me
so did you know started her sister and
so did my friend down this down the you
know down the hallway should I then
indeed you know go ahead and get
vaccinated and um but obviously the
consumers are doing this quality filter
but then they're also spreading this
news
so if you had um if the quality of
information were fixed the information
will quality were fixed and this process
that consumers have of checking out a
new story and then spreading it to their
friends and family that would obviously
be good right that would be really good
because the consumers are just filtering
out the news sending off what they think
are the more high quality uh news
stories to their friends and family that
would be that would be great however
the quality of the news is not exogenous
it's potentially endogenous right
somebody out there has produced that new
story which then that gets spread out
through the network so while that's our
Innovation or at least our claim to The
Innovation
um of what we're
trying to accomplish is understand how
all of this consumer sharing Behavior
affects the quality itself
so we have a simple model of information
Supply so we now have the reporters out
there or the you know the social
influencers who are possibly you know
testing products and so on and posting
about a product we have information
suppliers we're going to think of these
information suppliers as profit
maximizing I'm going to tell you what
their Pro how their what their profits
are and that actually is going to matter
a lot their profit maximizing and they
can produce a high or a low quality
story and of course high quality is more
expensive to produce
um we're going to look at
um mostly today
um our information suppliers who earn
revenues from consumers viewing the
story so what they're interested in is a
lot of consumers actually seeing their
their news story
they could also earn revenues these news
providers can do revenues from other
things too and we'll consider that
probably towards the end of today if I
have time
and so overall what this paper is doing
is endogenizing the quality of this news
product that then flows through the
network so we're going to see feedback
between what consumers are doing and
they're filtering and spreading of the
stories how that feeds back into what
producers are doing their incentive to
produce high or low quality which of
course feeds back into consumers
incentives to to spread stories to their
friends in them so that's overall the
structure of the model and our objective
um a little bit fixed ideas about our um
news story just to give a sense these
are kind of old examples but um
we should notice every time we open up
even a brick and mortar
um
news story we have opportunities to
share that story
so consumers see a story they share or
not with their friends consumers may
take attention we're not on a story
um and where is the where is the
producer getting its money it's getting
money from the advertising that goes
along with the stories right so
producers of information get money they
earn revenues from advertising that
accompanies their stories so and that
revenue is being generated right HP is
willing to put an ad here because they
think somebody's going to see it
okay so revenues from views is how we're
talking about this is sort of via this
advertising
um similarly our social media post
person I just learned who this person
was I didn't know I'm clearly you know
not social media Savvy but she's one of
the biggest influencers out there
um
[Music]
anyone anyone know who she is I just
kind of looked up you know the person
with the most followers and it wasn't
well I guess Ronaldo has more followers
I think he's the person literally with
the most followers on whatever but okay
so fine but she earns she earns revenues
right from the number of followers she
has obviously she also earns revenues by
people clicking on the products that she
endorses but she's also earning benefits
from a number
I also want to remind ourselves that uh
there are people out there who are
putting up false news okay this is just
some example of a Heart of Texas a
completely fictitious
um uh set of news stories that was
floated
um
that actually had effects so there was
actually protests and counter protests
um anyway just because they're going to
come into our story
uh in a little bit just remind ourselves
that there are these people out there
too which again were in Kevin's uh you
know Kevin's introduction as well so
we're all sort of worried also about
these fake news that's out there
all right so I hope we fixed ideas about
you know the environment that I'm trying
to study let me give you a summary of
the results as we always do and then
I'll go into the guts of the model OKAY
summary of the results
I'm going to be looking for an
equilibrium news veracity veracity here
is the average quality of a piece of
news where the probability that a piece
of news is high or low quality that's
what I'm calling veracity
um I'm going to talk mostly about the
market where producers get revenues from
consumers viewing their stories
um first of all we should recognize that
we have to have some low quality stories
circulating in any
um in any equilibrium
um so we've got to have some junk out
there
and why do we have to have some junk out
there because if a consumer thinks that
everything is high quality right the
consumer will pass on everything to her
friends and family
which means that a producer has no
incentive to actually produce high
quality because the consumer is just
going to pass it on so a producer would
have an incentive to deviate from this
high quality production
the first message we need something out
there to turn on this consumer filter
so you need something that makes the
consumers actually filter the news
um
the second this uh the second
um result is that this quality level
this veracity level is non-monatonic and
consumer connectedness so we're very
worried or at least we think we're
worried about this very connected market
and new spreads really widely and maybe
there's a reason for that actually we're
going to show that that there is a there
is a problem with that
um at first if nobody's connected then
producers don't really have an incentive
to produce high quality because it
simply stops right doesn't spread very
far add a couple of links then the the
producers who produce high quality
stories they're more they're more likely
to get through the consumer filter so
they get a benefit so there's an
incentive to produce high quality but as
the market gets extraordinarily well
connected right every you know the the
news spreads extraordinarily widely then
the incentive to produce high quality
goes down because anything you produce
is just going to get seen
right because it will get spread very
widely so there's this non-monotonicity
um uh effect of consumer connectedness
one quality
and when we have extraordinarily dense
networks so we also have a limiting
result right a limit result very similar
in other words the techniques are kind
of similar the sequence of equilibria
and we ask what happens and the limit
where the social connectedness goes to
Infinity
um in that limit we have something we're
calling the plight of the crowd which is
the the natural the intuition I was just
already giving it to you when news
spreads extraordinary School spreads
widely producers don't need to do
anything to get their news to be seen
and so then all news is low quality
what about misinformation
um the Heart of Texas folks this
information has this refined kind of um
well we thought it was surprising
um effect on the news Market clearly if
there's enough misinformation out there
that consumers don't trust anything
right it sort of overwhelms The Bona
Fide news producers then misinformation
will indeed to destroy a news Market
however if we have a relatively
well-functioning news Market that will
be defined want to be my
well-functioning so that consumers are
you know producers some producers are
producing high quality consumers are
filtering some of that and sending it
back onto their friends and feeds back
into high quality incentives
um introduce a little bit of information
misinformation just summon from
misinformation that actually has this
effect of increasing the incentives of
the Bonafide producers to produce high
quality
why is it it's because consumers are now
just a bit more skeptical than they were
they're they're going to filter more
strongly uh
the news that they see so the the the
um the signals they get have to be a bit
more precise than otherwise which then
gives producers the incentive to produce
high quality news because that's the
news that could get through the more
stringent filter
you have this perverse well I guess
surprising we thought surprising
um incentive um and actually
uh well maybe a five time I'll talk to
what I sort of my own uh you know sort
of about the world observations about
that oh that's what I just said okay
um if we take a look at a model where
producers don't earn revenues from
consumers seeing the news but earn
revenues from people acting on the news
so that might be a partisan News Network
we're going to get very different
results I don't know if I'll have chance
to talk about this but I can give you a
sense of the trade-offs perhaps in the
conclusion
uh one of the things to Just note here
to bullet off is it really matters right
it really matters what producers how
producers of news earn revenues right
that's going to matter that's not
surprising of course you know this is
their their incentives to produce news
and high quality news very much depends
on how they earn revenues and then of
course the consumer piece in the middle
there how what the consumers do
translates back to the rep
okay so that's the overview here's the
literature I'm not going to have a
chance to go through it all uh I can do
bits and pieces of it I have to add some
now I'm sure after this weekend this
week I'll have to add you know a lot
more papers to this list
um but relative to all of this all of
this work again what we think we're
doing which is new is we're endogenizing
this third-party decision so there's
people out there's there's this network
and people are interacting in this
network and now I've got a party out
there that's outside the network that's
interacting with the network they're not
just targeting the network right that we
know we know that you know producer
targets a particular part of the network
now this what the producer's incentives
actually depend on what consumers in
this network are doing that then feeds
back to what the producers are doing and
so on so it's an endogenous um decision
of what this third party is doing
okay let me give you an overview of the
model and get a little bit into the guts
of it
uh there's this weird thing on here that
I'm afraid if I touch it it'll oh okay
all right so the very beginning and it
says three three stages T equals zero
the first thing that happens is
producers choose
um some Observer choose observable
unobservable quality high or low quality
and then they broadcast their stories
they put their stories out there
consumers
um oh I'm sorry first this decision
leads to a story veracity level so this
is the probability that a producer has
produced a high or low quality story so
you think about as the average quality
that's out there
um consumers tune in to a fraction Tau
of the stories broadcasts so the
consumers are tuning in to broadcast
they're going to see any particular
producer story with fraction Tau okay
then there's if they actually do see a
story they say oh I'm going to read this
thing and see
um if I think it's high or low quality
to get a private signal of quality
they're going to update
um their belief as to whether the story
is high or low quality and then they're
going to decide to share the story or
not with their friends
um the shared stories go to their
neighbors
consumer C shared stories they update or
not their beliefs over about the story's
veracity so they can use um the
information they get from the sharing
decisions right like that you guys have
they can have them consumers can have
information about the consumers sharing
decisions to determine what they you
know have a final belief
um as to whether they think the story of
whether the story is high or low quality
at the very very end they eventually
learn the quality and earn payoffs
um how does this feedback into producers
incentives well consumers here are
seeing these stories right consumers are
seeing the stories so VH here is the
fraction of consumers that see a high
quality story this is the fraction of
consumers that see a low quality story
producers are earning revenues from the
number of or the probability that a
consumer sees their story which then
feeds back into their incentives to
produce higher low quality
okay so that's how the model works
all right
okay so what I'm going to do now is put
you know the model in each of these
places right and then solve for the
equilibrium our equilibrium what is our
equilibrium object here
um it's not a price it's by the veracity
level so P0 is going to we're not
talking about an equilibrium veracity
right is the this Market
um is in equilibrium or do we have high
velocity low veracity
et
cetera
all right so now let's um put guts into
each part of these um pieces here so the
producers we have a large number of
producers each has a random cost to
produce a high quality story C producing
a low quality story costs nothing
there's a distribution of these costs
agency it's continuous it's on the real
line so it can include negative costs
what are those negative costs doing
those negative costs or zero costs are
giving us some intrinsically motivated
producers so there's some producers out
there that want to produce high quality
no matter what essentially okay
um they're useful for us because we one
we think they're out there so it's good
to represent something we think that are
out there there are schools of
Journalism after all so it's good to
represent something we think is out
there in the world in our model it also
helps us get rid of a very very like
annoying
um uh unstable equilibrium at zero okay
so that's zero veracity so it's sort of
useful for two reasons
um producers cannot commit to high
quality right so they get a cough straw
they have to decide in that you know
will they want to indeed produce high
quality once they've gotten their costs
down they can't commit
um Quality is not directly observable to
Consumers so consumers can't just look
at a a news story and say Ah that's a
high quality news story however they can
get a signal as to whether that um story
is high or low quality at a higher low
quality story will generate different
signals to the consumers
right so I'll give show you the signal
technology in a little bit
um P0 as I've said before is story
veracity so it's the probability a story
is high quality and if producers have a
cutoff cost C for producing high quality
then P0 is H of C that's the probability
that a consumer producer has a cost
below some cutoff cost C
and um because my um I've got my uh h of
zero being strictly positive I don't
actually should have written that here
there is some minimum story veracity in
our market so I've just got producers
that are going to produce high quality
no matter what but not all of them
or yeah I've been identifying that as a
producer it's really the producers that
get that cloth straw I'm going to call
them intrinsically motivated
all right what about the demand side on
the demand side I've got n consumers
they're Linked In A directed Network
um D is a number of consumers I follows
and is followed by so this is like super
simple Network okay I have D neighbors I
send my Stu if I want to share something
I share to D people and I see
story shared by D people that's
um as I said before consumers tune into
news they see a story with probability
Tau that's exogenous one thing we're
working on which I I'm sure they won't
have time to talk about
to you know in this in this presentation
but love to talk about if anyone has the
time to you know over a coffee or
something we're trying to endogenize
this probability where consumers are
making a decision whether or not even to
tune into the news depending on how high
or low quality the news is but for now
there's a probability and it's um fixed
uh consumers of all along we would think
they would consumers value high quality
news their risk neutral and it's all
black box as to why they can't so I'm
not going to get into you know consumers
having reputations or anything like that
all I have is my consumers want to view
high quality news sorry they want to
share high quality news I want to share
high quality news with my mother
okay
um and if I share low quality news I
suffer for it I'm not going to say why
and there's lots of modeling that we
could do to say why I could be worried
about some collective decision that we
all have to make I could be worried
about my mother there could be reasons I
want to share high quality news but not
low quality
similarly I want to act on high quality
news and not act on low quality news and
I'm just black boxing those payoffs and
um
we're gonna then just sit and again make
our lives really uh really simple so if
we set these payoffs equal to each other
right then
um I just get myself a threshold right a
threshold belief of one half
which is the if my belief if I believe
that this story is high quality more
likely to be high quality than not so
that's the one half then I will share it
or I will act on it right so now the one
half just becomes you know thing that's
going to sort of take me through the
model and it's not important we could
sort of fiddle around with it
um in terms of these parameters
all right
for my consumers
are well well understood okay
uh all right so I promised you that the
consumers I guess in the previous slide
that the consumers evaluate stories that
they see so the consumers have an
evaluation technology so a consumer
tunes into a producer's broadcast they
see a producer story with probably Tao I
suppose they actually see it what do
they do they take a look at the story
and if the story is high quality the
consumer receives a signal H with Pro
with a probability row between one half
and one if the story is low quality the
consumer sees a signal out with
probability row between one half and one
so the the high story generates signal H
with greater probability I should have
written up here that there's only two
signals h l I realize I'm missing
something at the top there's two signals
H and L okay stories generate H and L a
high quality story is more likely to
generate an h a low quality story is
more likely to generate an l
and that's the signal technology right
whereas and this row you also observe um
uh people will also observe their
a realization of this signal precision
so rho this row here is also a random
variable and we're calling that a signal
precision
so uh by Bayes rule a consumer can say
they take P0 which is their initial
belief about whether a story is high or
low quality they get their signal H they
get their signal L they get their row
and then they update and they have this
posterior belief and that's P1 okay so
calling that P1
um
uh there we go that's some notation for
it okay so you can just use base rule to
solve for that P1
excuse me
um I should I didn't say this I should
have had this on the slide the consumer
given the assumptions I have on
preferences over sharing high and low
quality news if P1 is greater than a
half I share it if P1 is less than a
half I don't share it
all right so just a little picture to
help fix ideas of this this is my
directed Network those are my people
those are the News broadcasters
um they make some choice about whether
or not to produce high or low quality
news which produces it which gives us
this P0
okay so P0 in the end is going to be an
equilibrium so it's going to be both
what producers actually do and is what
produce consumers believe producers are
doing okay so it will be an equilibrium
all right so P0 is the result of
producers decisions to produce higher
low quality uh consumers are tuning in
to the producers broadcasts let's take a
look at that consumer over there on the
right that consumer left I guess uh yeah
that consumer this is popping up
okay okay that consumer uh Tunes in
let's suppose this consumer C is a piece
of news this consumer says oh what
should I do should I share this with my
friends
the consumer gets um a signal H or l and
a Precision row updates gets our P1 and
decides whether or not to share it the
consumer hit H and then suppose that
posterior is bigger than a half the
consumer shares it
done that's the extent of what we have
in terms of our sharing model I don't
have virality for example it just stops
and so we've one round of sharing
and of course we're doing that for
tractability right we could possibly
have more and more rounds of sharing and
the forces that come from the single
round of sharing are sufficient to get
us you know our objective which is to go
back to producers incentives
so I think of course it would be pretty
cool to think about further sharing and
further inferences that can people make
about the sharing exactly like what you
guys were doing but in this model we
just stopped right there
all right so that's how um the sharing
works in the model
okay
uh so
um we are looking for an equilibrium in
the market uh Supply equals demand is
not exactly you know I just wanted to
put it up there because it's fun to
write Supply equals demand what we're
looking for is P0 which is the
equilibrium veracity right
uh the way we have it set up is that
essentially we can just solve for a
symmetric Bayesian Nash equilibrium
again
it's great to follow you guys because so
this is all very it is all very um
familiar I'm even going to have a fixed
point with a 45 degree line so I got our
juices going to be able to look at look
at look at these uh equilibria all right
so the consumers are doing a best
response to P0 and producers are best
doing a best response to consumers
behavior and we're looking for the
equilibrium P0
all right so let's go ahead and derive
the best replies I have until three
perfect okay
let's go ahead and derive the best
replies
um
as I mentioned before given the
assumptions we have on consumers uh
preferences for sharing they're going to
share a story if their posterior belief
is bigger than a half and not shared if
it's less than a half
um so if we if a consumer's initial
belief is that the story is more likely
to be true than not this consumer is
going to share it unless they receive an
unfavorable signal l
right that sufficiently
accurate right that for the the are
sufficiently precise this row I is
sufficiently high
on the other hand if consumer initial
beliefs are that the story is more
likely to be low quality the consumer
won't share it unless they get a
favorable signal that is sufficiently
precise okay so you just work all of
this out
um so from that uh you can we derive
um these probabilities right so beta H
is our notation for the probability a
consumer will share a story a high
quality story if they have an initial
belief P0
and this Theta L is the probability with
initial belief P0 will share a low a low
quality story
um so I don't have the formulas up here
but I'm sure you can pretty much see how
see that this will be true is that the
probability of sharing a high quality
story is going to be greater than the
probability of sharing a low quality
story
um the probability of sharing
um either a high or low quality story is
increasing in the veracity right so
consumers
are more like if consumers have a a
higher initial belief than the
probability of the story is going to be
shared is higher so both the probability
of sharing a high and a low quality
story are increasing in the initial
belief
um but when we get to
um the story being more likely to be
true than not so P0 is greater than a
half
then the problem the increase in the
probability of sharing a high quality
story is less than the increase in the
probability of sharing a low quality
story
that's simply because a high quality
story is being shared frequently right
and it's the low quality stories that
kind of benefit from the higher initial
belief
what about the producers
uh the producers again are earning
revenues from the fraction of consumers
who view their stories
so um we have to think so where we want
to think of think think from a
producer's point of view what's the
probability if I produce a high quality
story what's the probability a consumer
is going to see it or what fraction of
consumers will see it which is again the
probability that a consumer sees it
so probably a consumer doesn't see the
story is when the consumer misses the
broadcast and no neighbors share so this
is the probability the consumer misses
the broadcast and this is the
probability that no neighbor shares it
right and that's the probability that
the consumer doesn't see the story
um same thing for VL
and so the only difference of course is
here is the H and the L right the
probability that your a neighbor is
sharing um the story
okay so the extra probability that a
consumer view is a high quality story is
just the difference between these two
probabilities and this is the source of
producers revenues right is the higher
probability of a consumer will see a
higher high quality story than a low
Quality Storage
all right so that that and just moving
to the next slide is exactly what I had
there but I just put it out in its form
it's full of full form
so the supplier is going to produce high
quality whenever
the revenue additional Revenue it can
get from producing high quality exceeds
its cost
right benefits you seek sauce costs
um so the high quality Supply is just
the probability that A supplier gets a
cost that's lower than this added value
um and that's going to be continuous
because our distribution function is
continuous so that's the high quality
Supply
okay we all good
okay so now I'm going to start putting
them all together and start putting it
together so I have to start
characterizing a bit Supply and then
I'll go back to demand so the first
thing to notice is that this high
quality Supply is single peaked in P0
and is strictly decreasing for P0
greater than a half I'll show you in a
picture of this in this a second excuse
me
and really the key to this is that the
supply is coming from this additional
probability
or the additional likelihood that a high
quality story is seen rather than a low
quality story and so then that's so that
this is single Peak is just coming from
the fact that the that both of these
um
probabilities are increasing in P0 but
they're increasing in P0 at different
rates
um and especially when P0 gets very high
the the increase the benefit for high
quality stories is less than the benefit
for low quality stories and then
especially so when we get to P0 bigger
than a half
all right so first good news is an
equilibrium exists for oh I haven't I'm
going to be really worried about social
connectedness they've been disappeared
for a while but it's going to come back
so first just fix a d right I follow 10
people 10 people follow me that's it
whatever number you want to give me an
equilibrium exists for any key
uh the equilibrium is a P0 it's a
thoracity level so
um if I have P0 here or my x-axis and I
have Supply on
um my y-axis and here is the lowest
amount sorry the minimum Supply right
Supply will not fall below this amount
because I've got some cost draws right
I've got some uh cost draws
excuse me that are below zero that
consumers will take
all right oh yeah I was just putting
this up again this is the source of
producers revenues
so Supply
um
looks like this relative to P0 it's
single piece
right and I don't have a hat yet but
after a half it's always going to be
declining
so the the equilibrium is just where the
Supply hits the 45 degree line and so
consumers believe P0 feeds into producer
Supply this is the uh and this then
feedback into producer consumers
and that's our equilibrium
with an equilibrium where consumers
beliefs are exactly the
um
a piece of veracity are exactly the rate
at which producers are producing quality
did you know the thing about the slopes
that makes it a stable
know do you have control of the slope at
the point of intersection to make it uh
getting to that I have control over the
slope when P0 is greater than a half but
not before that's the next slide
okay so one of the things that I'm going
to do is um
is think about the maximal veracity
equilibrium I drew this one so this is
the maximal brought because this is a
downward sloping line here The Producers
Supply is downward sloping for P0 bigger
than a half and that's so but we're
jumping ahead a couple sides so first of
all I'm going to be thinking about the
maximal velocity equilibrium so that's
going to be my object that I'm going to
be looking for uh I don't really know
much about the slope here until
um
until I hit a half
so I don't really know much
um
but I'm going to focus on when I can get
a maximal veracity equilibrium with P0
bigger than a half why do I like P0
bigger than a half well that is when a
story is more likely to be true then I'm
sorry more likely to be high quality
than not
which fits exactly with consumers comes
from consumers preference but okay so
where I'm going now is I have this
existence of this equilibrium of
existence with equilibria and I'm going
to talk about a maximal velocity of
equilibrium and now my objective I you
know it's there is how does this
equilibrium behave when um with d d is
the social connectedness so we're all
here because we like networks okay so D
what is D going to do to my um
so is this some preliminaries there's a
non-mono tonic effect on of D on this
extra probability of of a of a story
being seen and I've already talked about
this intuition already
so um if we start out with low density
and we increase d by a little bit so we
increase d by a little bit so we're over
here what's happening is that the
probability a high quality is being seen
increases more than the probability that
a low quality story increases
but as we um keep going if we start to
be out here right then high quality
stories are seen very very frequently
and the increase of of a link right add
another link is benefiting high low
quality stories more than high quality
stories
so we have this non-monotonicity on
Delta V which of course this is the
source of Producers Supply Revenue so
that's going to be affecting
um
their
people their their response so there's a
Lemma this Delta V is single peaked in D
and the limit it goes to zero okay so
putting this all together here's our one
of our main results either the maximal
velocity equilibrium is less than a half
for all D or
if we get up there so that we've got
enough action going on in our on our
consumer side
um there exists these threshold values
of d a lower one and a Higher One and in
between the two
um the natural velocity equilibrium is
greater than a half
and so that's our picture which
demonstrates this so here's our half
right I know that after a half the
supply is that has its downward slope
right my natural velocity equilibrium is
right here
um all right sorry I'll get that we got
some nods all right however as part of
the other results that I have I
mentioned earlier if D gets
extraordinarily large right so going
back to here right
Delta V goes to zero right because both
high and low quantity stories are being
seen with probability one and we have
what we call a flight of the crowd
okay so it's extremely well connected
Market stories travel very widely why
should producers do anything to get
their stories seen okay let me just give
a quick message uh I don't have time to
I'm not going to do my misinformation
agents because I don't have time
uh but I can return to it in a question
I do want to re to to bring this
analysis
uh back to some literature out there
that studies media markets right after
all we're trying to understand the media
so historically
advertising Revenue
decreased newspapers despondent
dependence on sponsors so think you know
100 years ago or maybe more
I think it's actually more than 100
years ago where newspapers were
sponsored by trade unions or political
parties right so they were dependent on
sponsors for news then there's an
innovation in the American Media Market
or newspaper Market especially Market
newspapers that they're no longer
dependent on sponsors but now Macy's is
putting an ad in the newspaper this then
frees up the newspaper from having to
serve its sponsor so this wonderful
paper shows that it reduces media bias
I don't have bias in my model as you may
have noticed but I have quality
and our message is in today's connected
world or perhaps hyper-connected world
the revenue based on Advertising
um
uh model of you know that's how that's
how newspapers or you know media are
making its money is through advertising
right that means
their revenue is based on people just
seeing their stuff so you're not selling
news you're selling ads essentially
right it can have detrimental effects on
quality in a hyper hyper-connected
Market
so I think
um I'm out of time I could jump to my
concluding slide or I could just start
taking questions
all right so I had this bit I see of
course we never have enough time in any
detox
so here's my concluding slide it's a
simple model of market for news my
consumers are rational
uh they value sharing and acting on high
quality news our proof my producers are
profit maximizing they have a higher
cost for higher quality news equilibria
exists with high quality news but a low
quality I didn't actually have this as a
result but I sort of just told you why
that's true low quality news circulates
in any equilibrium I didn't get to show
you this misinformation can increase
high quality news production but I think
you can see how because it makes
consumers have uh more uh their their
the the Threshold at which they're going
to send on a story is now more stringent
it's higher right you need a more
precise signal which is benefits high
quality news more than low quality news
um non-monitonistic and social
connectedness
um high quality news production
things that we have to do and Dodges
Network links right so links here have
clear extra information
um externalities so what does that mean
you know here links are good and they're
bad depending on how many of them we
have
uh business models I hope this is next
yes industrial organization of producers
I actually now have a whole different
understanding of subscription business
models right so so there are producers
which prevent actually their news from
traveling
right you can't actually just send a
piece of news off to your friend now you
have to subscribe to the news to
actually see I think there's or maybe a
limit of how many articles
what what's going on there might be
actually trying to restrict so wait a
sister herself and force so that your
news doesn't travel too fast too too
widely
um and my last bullet point oh yes very
big one which um I don't maybe you guys
will see what people are working on that
um now I have high and low quality news
but clearly people are sharing news for
other reasons people are sharing news
because maybe it's surprising
because it's funny it's shocking there's
all sorts of studies out there of why
people are sharing news that's a
different dimension of our product and I
think it would be interesting to do a
similar kind of exercise where we're
looking at consumer sharing behavior and
then how that feeds back to producers
and feeds back to Consumers and so
is there any questions for Rachel
foreign
why did your Edge function have like a
concave behavior before half and convex
Behavior after half like what was the
rationale behind that the the which
behavior there's a lot of halves in my
model so
um I mean the producer Supply uh there
was an H function oh yes oh H okay I
didn't hear the H yes that just comes
from the um phase rule
it just comes from Bayes Rule and our
um our
uh
signal technology so I can show you it I
I can show you it later if you put up
the equations for this beta H function
this beta H function and you look at
that beta H function right that's what's
going to give you that half
right that's all it is it's just
mechanical that's nothing mysterious
it's just coming from Bayes Rule and the
fact that we have this consumers wanting
to share well it does come from
consumers want to share if they're
posterior is bigger than a half so
that's that's coming from their
preferences but once we fix that number
that's the number that's going to feed
into uh this probability of sharing
foreign
I guess like this is maybe because you
didn't get the misinformation part but I
kept wondering why you're insisting on
calling it high in low quality as
opposed to true and fake news right it's
a good question at one point it was true
in false news so at one point we had
that as our um as what we were doing
then it got kind of hairy as to what did
it mean true and false news about what
and then then people were worried you
know people were worried well is it
about an issue like is it there there is
you know is it about an issue like
vaccines was it that true or not about
vaccines so then we changed it to high
and low quality news where high quality
news is news that's worthy of acting
upon
so this is like the the
um the research
you know we all go through this right
we're trying to model this very
complicated phenomenon we're trying to
capture a slice of it and we attach
words to our math and then the words
send readers off in One Direction it
doesn't quite match what we're trying to
do and so then we got to go back and so
we've settled on high and low quality in
the sense that it covers enough of the
cases that we're what we're going for
that's how we landed on it
any other question
can you get a break so we will have a
break from three to three Thirty and um
and then after the break we will
continue with Alex touch
thanks very much
[Applause]